We're not even married to
Baking It as the name.
It could be Baketacular,
or Bakescalibur, or...
That's not bad.
Masterbakers!
Absolutely not.
Welcome to Baking It.
One team will win the
$50,000 prize.
I was gonna say it's the journey
not the money.
Uh oh. Ha ha!
That's what my lower back tattoo says.
I'm not gonna go so far as to say
we were born for this.
I mean, some of us were.
I would say having kids was the best
thing that ever happened to me
until this show.
Ha ha, really?
Now this is like, my real baby.
You know what I mean?
Yes.
What are you making?
Pudding, three ways.
I did a lot of those in college.
Pudding, three ways?
Now our judges are here to do what
grandmothers do best.
Judge you because they love you and
think you can do better.
It's great.
Delicious.
So good.
I don't agree with you on that.
I think it's undercooked.
The grandchildren tell me all the time,
"Oh grandma, you shouldn't say that."
And I just say, "Tough s**t."
I want a cake that makes me go...
"What?!"
And then, "Mmm!"
Time to get dirty.
I love the holidays, and that's what
baking is all about.
It brings people together.
I could not be left alone with this cake because
I know what I do with king cakes at home.
We don't!
Oh, what, what, what were you thinking?
I–
What?
Y-you?
Ah!
Ha ha ha!